be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
man let me tell y'all something man let
me tell y'all something
man limit us man man y'all right here
look here's the thing folks all right
here's the thing
all right here's the thing house of X is
done house of X is finished and it is
legit oh hey by the way um what is it
right now it's it's around 8:30 a.m.
mountain time so that's 10:30 a.m.
Standard Time or Eastern Standard Time
ah so we'll say at about 11:30 a.m. give
or take time for my my editor to edit
the video for it for it to go up and for
you guys to be able to watch it will say
11:30 a.m. Eastern Standard Time I will
be live on twitch twitch TV slash I am
Rob Jefferson coming out will be like a
live Q&A while I'm playing destiny -
it'll be pretty awesome
okay so so here's so here's the thing
right okay so I am hyped for the
conclusion of house of X like I am I do
this is ha okay obviously hitman set
stuff in place for like Dawn of X right
and I told people he was good I told man
penetration I mean II action for 25
years folks I know what I'm talking
about I told people this was going to
happen right I told people this is
exactly what's gonna happen that
Jonathan Hickman is gonna plant the
seeds for like Dawn of X right it's not
just gonna end it's not gonna be a self
contained thing it's like it's basically
like like dark ray in the Fantastic Four
right like if you want to understand
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four run
you have to cover the Fantastic Four
Dark Reign story and maybe we should
write like maybe we should but like if
you want to understand he was run you
have to cover that because like that's
the beginning of it all that's how it
all starts so so here's the thing man
like okay so so initially this picks up
down in like the Citadel right because
the big question people have had here is
where is more McTaggart right like
where's Maura McTaggart and all of this
stuff that we've seen in house so that's
because in all of the other alternate
realities all the other lives as she's
lived whatever you want to call them
like she's always been there where she
at we haven't seen her once this entire
time and there's been all these theories
floating around like I saw theories in
the comments section people were saying
that Professor Xavier is actually more a
MacGyver like which is a cool theory is
wrong but it's a cool theory all right
Maura McTaggart is there and here's a
crazy thing this really kind of like
this discussion between between Maura
and and Magneto and Xavier or they
basically say if we do this if we start
this process there's no going back here
like if we do this if
we start this process there's no going
back there's there's no unring this Bell
right like will cross the line that we
can't come back from and Xavier response
is I understand like I get what it is
it's coming so literally here's it's the
coolest thing in the world see this is
why I love Jonathan Hickman right
because Jonathan Hickman is really
really good at doing these scenarios
we're like a character who's really
powerful will basically go out into the
world in just be like you're all screwed
like you are all screwed do I love this
okay so so here's so you have to
understand the x-men history right like
the action have constantly been
persecuted cast off then been
manipulated been been screwed over been
left hanging over and over and over and
over again constantly happening in the
realm of Marvel Comics right like
humanity's always stood idly by and
either let them be attacked or actually
gone after them themselves right the
Friends of humanity right like all these
are groups of purifiers and in the
marauders of mr. sinister but even the
superhero community like the Avengers
and so on even most of them are just
kind of stood by and not really done
anything Cyclops made that point in
Avengers vs. x-men right you guys
remember that conversation between
Cyclops inand in Captain America where
it were and even talking to like Reed
Richards it's kind of like you guys have
willfully stood by and let us be
persecuted you guys have willfully stood
by and let these groups come after us
and eliminate our kind and were were you
during the events of of EA's for
extinction were the Avengers to help
rescue us during es for extinction where
were the Avengers during the events
during during the story arc of of God
loves man kills were were were you when
when we had the purifiers coming after
us and we had the right coming after us
and the friends of humanity coming after
us and factor 3 coming after us where
were you when all this was going on and
so is it's so cool because at this point
humanity's like we've had enough I'm
sorry meeting cons like we've had enough
we're done so Xavier puts on his helmet
right puts on his helmet and addresses
the world and says world humanity here's
the deal in the coming in the coming
days in the coming months in the coming
period of time you will learn that we
here mutants on the island of cacoa have
basically created drugs here that are
pharmaceutical fountains of youth
basically right big they can cure people
of most cancers they can extend your
life by five years they can cure most
mental illnesses now there was a time
when I would have just given you these
drugs because what I wanted was a
peaceful coexistence between humans and
and mutants what I wanted was for us to
be able to bond together now keep in
mind the whole of the superhero
community and all of humanity is
she's like there was a time when all I
wanted was peace but you didn't want
that the superheroes let us die time and
time again you as humanity either came
after us or stood by and did nothing so
I'm not giving you anything
I'm not giving you any drugs you're
gonna have to live your life as best you
can if you want them you have to pay for
them and it's just like dude this is
legit because it's Xavier just like
sticking that knife in and just being
like like you could have had the life
you could have had this dream you could
have had things but you could have had
the perfect world but instead you had to
be idiots instead you had to be selfish
you had to be vile and you had to be
cruel and you had to turn your guns on
us despite the fact did we'd really done
nothing wrong and so because that if you
want these drugs if you want to be able
to have these things and then there are
two form of payments that come into this
the first is you have to accept that
Cocola is going to be a nation state
unto itself that we basically want to be
autonomous that we do not answer to any
existing government out there aside from
the United Nations we are on par with
China and the United States and all
these various nations that exists out
there that govern themselves and so long
as it'll violate things like the Geneva
Conventions then were fun and the second
is that at Birth the moment they are
born any mutant out there in the world
can claim krakoa
is citizenship which means if your child
grows to be 13 years old and her mutant
and his or her mutant powers manifest
and they're reading online about how the
island of kokoa is is a nation state
that they can at that point in time say
I want to be a citizen of kokoa and
leave and there's nothing their parents
can do to stop them that Amy mutant
anywhere can make that claim and they
are now protected under the laws of
Kokua that the laws of man no longer no
longer affect mutants it's a crazy thing
like if you wanted to if you want these
drugs if you want to be able to improve
your life you have to be able you like
you you have to do this now here's the
thing is this kind of reading between
the lines is because it's sort of like
and if you decide to make a move against
us all hell's gonna break loose it's one
of the coolest things you know he's like
from this day forward mutant con is
governed by mutant laws not mankind's
laws these are not negotiable terms
there's no sitting down at a table and
getting us to basically finagle and
change our minds or anything like that
like this is basically how this is going
to be we're asking you for a better life
and in return we will give you the same
like that's basically how this is going
to work and it's so it's it's so um
think this is the best this is the best
part right this is the
part right here he basically says if you
if you find yourself in a position
asking the question who are we as
mutants to make terms like this we're
the future right like fur fur countless
eons you as human beings have gone to
bed and woke and woke up believing the
world would be the same believe in the
world would be as it always was that's
not true we are as true inheritors we
are the next step in human evolution so
here's the reality of the world that you
live in while you slept
the world changed and it's just like
Jude like it's one of the coolest things
Xavier is like Xavier is not pulling any
punches man it's crazy he really feels
like magneto here it's like dude this is
this is awesome man like this is legit
who's your the thing - we end up getting
like the quiet Council of kokoa like the
full-on Council of the twelve basically
albeit we're missing a single person
like a Red King right so we get
Professor X magneto and apocalypse this
is gonna be the coolest thing cuz peers
like manage a new epochal do the pocke
looks like once you get to the end of
the story like the end of this issue
apocalypse do this just kind of like
okay okay apocalypse I see you man like
I do I see what's going on like it is
it's it's legit then you get mr.
sinister you get Exodus and you get
mystique right now mr. sinister is
pretty self-explanatory we have a video
explaining him we don't have a video
explaining Exodus basically Exodus is a
super powerful telepath and telekinetic
right like he's way up there in terms of
his powers it's it's nuts what all he
can do but he like mr. sinister was
created by the villain apocalypse and of
course mystique speaks for itself
you got Sebastian Sean Emma Frost which
I love those choices because Sebastian
Shaw it's basically a guy who just turns
any kind of any kind of energy or or
attack this made against him intellect
physical strength not to mention he's
got all kinds of fingers and different
pies you know that he's been involved in
over the years and and really has a lot
of influence and pulls throughout the
world Emma Frost is the exact same way a
storm Jean Grey and Nightcrawler this is
a cool choice because this is like the
original x-men basically and or at least
not the original but like the giant-size
x-men more or less it was a great call
back to that and then of course you've
got cypher who speaks for cacoa and
greco being the island they all do they
all basically reside on now this
actually goes directly into the first
meeting of the council the first meeting
of the twelve and is one of the coolest
things because as this all basically
begins to go into discussion what they
end up doing is bringing out their first
prisoner their first act as a council
which is an action of judgment and what
they the first thing they're bringing
out is Sabretooth now remember
Sabretooth was the one who was sent on a
mission by
Xavier and all them into the into the
world and then basically kind of you
know went forward with his own agenda
and once he was caught up to about
mystique and all them they brought him
back we saw that earlier in the house of
X storyline and so it's it's crazy
because what you end up basically
getting is kind of this debate that
begins to run on between all these
different guys this kind of discussion
that takes place and the question is if
we are a if we are a nation that
believes that it's wrong for Humanity to
take our lives then we have to in turn
believe the opposite that is wrong for
he meant for us to take the lives of
humans now in reality this is more of a
safeguarding thing right if humanity
begins to come to the belief that kokoa
is really nothing more than a warring
nation state is one of these places
where mutants are gathering forces so
they can eventually launch attack
against humanity and there's credible
reason to believe that well then humans
will strike first it's just the way that
it is but if they kind of uphold this
rule that we are a nation that basically
we don't attack humans and humans don't
attack us they stay away and we stay
away it creates an uneasy alliance it
still works and it still serves its
purpose but it's one of those things
worse kind of like we can't basically
decide like we can't be the judge jury
and executioner for a group of people
out there who don't follow our laws but
at the same time can we are we going to
be the kind of people who execute our
own mutants like is that the rule that
we're gonna play because if we're if we
create this place to safeguard the
mutant population and then start
executing them for crimes that they
commit is that okay and so basically
what they end up doing is kind of
sitting down and creating these kind of
laws of krakoa basically these laws are
they're all going to follow these laws
are they're all going to obey and so
where you end up having this this sort
of discussion taking place and
saber-toothed watching it unfold
saber-toothed begins to begins to come
to the realization of the belief that
the entire Council begins to kill him
from there it starts getting into a
discussion of like what's really home
here right I mean flake from from storms
perspective in the way she makes the
argument home really is a matter of
possession right you know you possess
your home you own your home therefore
you live inside your home but because of
the fact that Cocola is inherently a
mutant Agricola is providing them with a
with a dwelling a place to live there's
actually site for who kind of makes that
argument on behalf of kokoa
the technically it would be ownership of
a mutant and so because of that it kind
of begins to beg the question if cacoa
is going to allow them a place to live a
place of residency of sorts then it can
they truly in turn call it something
that they own and if they do can they
treat it like something that they own
that is to say just treat however they
want you and the answer to that question
is no that's not the case and so by
virtue of all these discussions that are
going on what they do is create three
laws the three law
of cacoa make more mutants which is to
say grow their wrench because right now
our numbers are severely limited so
somewhere along the line Humanity is
going to make an attack humanity is
going to strike and when they do we need
to have a mutant population large enough
to be able to withstand such an attack
the second thing is murder no men do not
murder humanity unless they put us in a
situation where we have to write so
defending our land is just caused to
murder a human will murder in them
willy-nilly like saber-tooth did that's
not OK and then third respect the sacred
land respect the land of krakoa these
are very three basic and fundamental but
exceedingly important laws because it's
really one of these things worked by the
grace of krakoa goes the mutant
population right they serve at the
pleasure of kokoa at any point in time
he could just kick them all out or just
sink himself and they would have nowhere
to live whatever the case is it mean any
number of things could happen it could
turn on them there's there's a whole
bunch of things that could take places
so it's respect the land of cacoa
respect the house in which we're being
given residence that's basically how
this whole thing goes down so then they
start asking the question if the law if
one of the sacred laws is we cannot kill
any man outside of defense that is to
say you basically trying to get away and
there's no way for us to get away
meaning they corner us or something like
that or they attack our sacred land then
like what do we do with saber-toothed
and the response is well we can't just
kill him instead we are going to exile
him and so what they do is really really
cool here because the initial response
would be if we're going to exile him
just send him out into space I'm sorry
to send him out into the world the
problem with this is that if they did
that one they'd be basically like
sending him to suicide somebody
somewhere would try to kill him and two
while that probably wouldn't work what
he could do is dump all his knowledge
about krakoa and the goings on in mutant
society out into the highest bidder give
it to the government different things
like that and literally become the the
means by which the entire island of Ko
Ko would just come crashing down around
them literally just become the lynchpin
that pulls that they just pulled out and
the whole thing comes crashing down and
so what they end up doing is exiling him
deep down inside of Pecola itself they
literally lock him away down inside of
inside of this this living Island and so
it's kind of nuts because from there
they basically like celebrate their safe
haven they celebrate the place they're
in they're right it's just kind of okay
let us go forward from here and mutants
like all these mittens who arrived here
Amit's were arriving every single day
all these mutants who were showing up
here are celebrating this newfound
freedom that they have and as
seen that Hickman's building it up
because he's building it up in such a
way to work they're celebrating freedom
they're celebrating living in a place
where they don't have to worry about
being persecuted by humanity and where
you have like Xavier and and magneto who
are who are talking with one another and
who are who were basically sort of
enjoying this moment and saying look at
this world that we've created what
you've got is Apocalypse watching it all
go down and here is my question here's
my question Rob core here's man here's
what I want here's what I want to know
cuz I feel like I feel like things are
about to pop off here's what I want to
know yes apocalypse is on the council
yes apocalypse is there to observe but
as apocalypse is he was he going to step
in when when the time comes when
Humanity shows up on the doorstep of
kokoa
and just starts unleashing all kinds of
craziness is apocalypse going to act or
will apocalypse stand down and simply
just say whoever survives this whole
thing is worthy like they're worthy of
continued existence but those are those
mutants who were there if you cannot
survive and protect your own land you
were never worthy of living in the first
place right his philosophy of social
Darwinism that's what I want to know or
is apocalypse does he have more
nefarious plans it is legit I love this
story with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]